uh and one day the party runs out
to your point
um I I learned this quite a few years
ago that a greatest achievement someone
could ever have is to see their
grandchildren so when people talk about
their parent like you having kids and
how is it gonna affect your kids it's
like
the byproduct of you having kids will be
your grandkids and that's when you'll
see the and reap the rewards of
everything you'll see everything come
full for what's it called Full Circle
full circle you'll see everything come
you'll see everything come full circle
and it's more so that you need to have
kids in order to have grandkids and if
you leave it too late you'll be in a
position where you'll be 60 and you may
see other family members with grandkids
but you have nothing to show
for your life through your lines I'm
gonna like come up with the travel
picture or whatever
but nobody's gonna look at it because no
one's going to Care yeah I don't care
like you said he said I probably
wouldn't care about big grandchildren or
whatever do you think that A Life That's
only about you is worth living where
it's just me me me selfish all the time
it's everything's about me and my
feelings but if you if you if you're
alone forever that's that's what life's
about it's you like to me life's about
people and if I don't if I don't have a
family to share it with like oh yes
they'll die in fact I don't I don't no I
have sister I have brothers
and nephews so like they wouldn't die
before they may absolutely absolutely
you know what I'm in yeah there's no one
that will be at your funeral talking
about how hard you worked in your great
career yeah
at large most people would say I'm very
successful at my age it means nothing if
I don't get married
no I mean it's not a different like like
I think a girl get married or nothing
you don't have children and if I don't
get married like honestly a girl that
can't get married is a loser
so just like that just like yeah just
like just like because you lose her
loser I mean look at low loads because
we still study what was she
mentioned grandchildren okay so if you
have children but you're not out of out
of marriage I'd be a loser yeah but you
have grandchildren and you have that the
memories he was talking about you still
have that no but you won't have that be
okay so I raised my kids at every
statistical disadvantage that's selfish
on me no but let's listen you have
children they're grown they've had
grandchildren and then now you're
divorcing for whatever reason have you
not still had that life that he's been
talking about you still have the
grandchildren you still have it there
you still have that full circle okay I
would say I grew up in a film I have
nine siblings I have two parents they've
been married for like 30 years it is not
the same when there's two Christmases
it's not the same like the I I talk to
people from like split family homes and
tell them about like the Traditions that
me and my family have like we go as
adults take pictures with Santa every
year we all go to Fourth of July the
whole family kind of like we do these
events all year it's actually stressful
because my mom expects us to be at so
much [__] but you don't get that in a
single parent home and when I talk to
people from single parent homes they're
jealous like they wish they had that and
it's like why would I put my kids at
every statistical disadvantage because
it's not about me anymore once I have
children who [__] my happiness no but
the children the point I made is the
children are grown up now they're not
kids like you've had your marriage you
they lived in a two-parent household
they've grown up they've gone to college
uni whatever they're older they've had
children you have grandchildren but now
the only difference the only difference
is you weren't married yeah that's
that's what I'm trying to say oh am I
still with the husband I just get
divorced later no like you weren't
married oh I I'm okay with like like a
committed yeah like I know the laws are
kind of [__] for men so if it if it was
something similar but you don't get the
government involved fine but so then the
reason no I would say you still need a
ring it's just like there's people that
do it on outside of the government like
that you know they do it in their church
or whatever so you need the ring for
that whole grandchildren
I mean yeah you should you should be
married before you have kids whether
it's with the government or not so
you're saying you should is it because
of God or because of government because
that it that gives the kids the best
outcomes that you've got married yes but
you can still be in a household where
you're together and not married and the
children have both mom and dad in the
house it's possible they have a happy
home it's possible but not probable okay
they have a happy home and then you have
grandchildren and all that stuff
is that that's still the goal no that's
still happiness no the goals yeah I mean
I mean you had the chips
but he doesn't he doesn't want to marry
you no no no I don't know you just said
the goal was having grandchildren and
having your future in your loins and all
that sort of stuff which you can still
have without a ring that's what I'm
trying to say you can so you can have
all of those things without a ring my
point was that is one thing one aspect
that not having kids or looking to have
kids with the person you want to find
that you come across in your later ages
as a woman your goal is the ring that's
that from what I've learned is it the
ring or is it the children it's
commitment oh it's both the ring it's
the Legacy it's the man that you respect
it's the man that you look up to and
you've got him and you've got him to
commit so you got him to commit but you
didn't have kids
I don't even know what these
hypothetical situations
okay this is this is the goal I want to
get married and then have kids I don't
if it's outside of the government fine
but I still want to be married in some
level see what marriage first and then
children yeah I think I think it's quite
selfish to do the other first and a lot
of girls trap guys in order to do it
and like I think it's it's selfish
because you're thinking of yourself
before the kids but with the kids first
so no matter what age you're at you're
you're waiting for the ring before the
kids yeah I mean how old are you sorry
I'm 25 25 so then if you meet the guy
this are you dating married now engaged
like what's your I don't have a
boyfriend no so then if you met someone
and then your date in it's going well
but then he doesn't propose until
I don't know you're 28 29 and then you
don't have kids until your eggs are like
you said after 30 your eggs are now like
would is is that is that that's you're
okay with that then after two years cut
it off yeah I'd say yeah two years
so if you're dating someone for more
than two years yeah where's the
commitment why hasn't he done it no he's
proposed but you're but you're not
married yet you can have a ring but you
can get you can get married and go to a
courthouse I don't need a wedding 25 and
then he proposed at the 27 you get
married the next day yeah I mean
honestly I'm a I'm like I've never cared
about a wedding like because I don't
think it's about the wedding it's about
a marriage yeah yeah so who who like I
mean if I got married I could do it at a
courthouse just make sure my parents and
my siblings could come so if he doesn't
propose after 27 are you you're back out
there looking for someone else yeah who
probably you're getting yeah then I'd be
on discount yeah Beyonce fail so you
just pick whoever will take you I'd pick
the best bet I could
that's the saying like the best bits
yeah the one that ticks some of your
boxes you won't just pick anyone because
I want 27 I need to just quickly get
married because
we'll go for someone that that is
you're only as valuable as your options
I remember I remember a girl saying to
me yeah I remember a girl saying to me
that
there were certain type of men that
constantly moved to her
so she had to look at it and say well if
these are the type of guys that moved to
me then I need to readjust and find a
way to see what these guys are about so
if you're a girl and you go out and
every single man that moves